this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know the cash shop is the number
one finance app on the App Store what
you might not know is that you can also
put cash up in your wallet with the cash
card
it's got boosts mmm it's got great
safety features no credit check needed
to get one we'll talk about this more
later on in the show download the cash
app for free on the App Store or Google
Play mark what's up how you doing okay
well first of all we've got a huge show
in Los Angeles this week and there are
still tickets left on The Late Show the
first show sold out we're playing The
Wiltern that's where I shot my special
incorrigible the first Netflix special I
did so we're coming back we're doing two
second show will sell out so you know
I'm just posted about it and do my due
diligence but we're doing that so that's
very cool I love playing Los Angeles I
love doing my hour in Los Angeles too a
lot of times I'm doing these spots like
15 minutes or 20 minutes spots in there
at the you know at the Comedy Store
Laugh Factory The Improv but there's
gonna be a full hour follow-the-leader
tour just like I do on the road and I'm
doing it on - I'm doing the road what
I'm doing is I'm bringing the road to
[ __ ] - home you know we did the home
show we did the home show in Montclair
New Jersey now we're doing the other
home show in in Los Angeles so there's
that so get your tickets now so there's
that and then there's also new merch
these shirts [ __ ] are I this is the
best shirt we ever had it's just gone I
mean it's it's there's still you know we
got we make them to order or something
like that but it's all good so you can
get them whenever you want but they we
got these shirts and if you want to show
someone that you [ __ ] no matter what
you do it wouldn't make a [ __ ] Dan
all you got to do is go
on the gong chrisley calm and get the
[ __ ] wouldn't make a shirt and it's a
long sleeve it's a cool one man it's
kind of like they want to have on now
this is a and an undefeated shirt which
I've been wearing a lot lately because
I'm [ __ ] trying to make a bowl of
[ __ ] you know I'm not even trying to but
it's just like people look at me and
they go like this is that a [ __ ] bowl
of pasta and I'm like what and they're
like oh sorry dude I thought you were a
bowl of pasta for a quick sec cuz you
got way too much [ __ ] sauce and then I
just say nah it's just because any of
this clothing
I got no dents I got no [ __ ] dents no
dents anyway get this wouldn't make a
dent t-shirt on Chris D'Elia calm and to
show you to show you and to show your
[ __ ] crew
no dents 2019 that's the hashtag no
dents 2009 no [ __ ] scrapey dents and
these bank accounts do it you don't roll
around in a jalopy in 2019 you got a
[ __ ] dent list tricked-out bank
account anyway solo sends a show and the
new shirts man do you I can't wait to
see this [ __ ] the cult in these these
den shirts bro or any of these shirt you
know what I mean
freak hunch you can get whatever [ __ ]
shirt you want but those are the hot
ones anyway that's it I'm live on my app
hi babies I see you all on my app and
well this week is a new week and every
week you can say that because every week
is a new week but every but sooner or
later
wigs are gonna stop because the world is
gonna explode so while we still can
we say every week we say it's a new week
it's a new week so well [ __ ] hot news
for the congratulations called man
carpel Angie Sam fine is going to jail
at least 25 years and I feel really bad
for her I feel like I feel like so
replant she sent down the the rapper
saudade cheese 75 is going to jail
because first of all he plead he pled
guilty yeah to pleaded pleaded no he
pled guilty to the or he described what
he did with the underage girl and then
then he got on then he got probation and
the judge was like hey don't say
anything gang-related in your songs and
don't put anything gang-related on
Instagram and if you say tre way the
gang [ __ ] on your Instagram or on the
songs you're gonna go to jail and you're
in violation of breaking your probation
so what tint on Chi 70 Poppins did was
[ __ ] brandished a gun at a gun fight
and also got [ __ ] hit for
racketeering which is how do you even do
that anymore like are you in the Mafia
you know well I didn't even know what
really racketeering was and it's just
kind of like being around it's basically
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're not really doing the
crime but you're there and you're
showing people that you have a gun
racketeering often associated with
whoops and whan fire went back he had it
and then went back racketeering often
associated with organized crime is the
act of getting involved in a dishonest
and fraudulent business dealing or
offering a service to solve a problem
that wouldn't otherwise exist the lot of
us so it's not like you're really doing
it but you're like hey dude I got some
secret [ __ ] if you need to the list
includes gambling kidnap murder wow that
really took a jump it includes [ __ ]
washing your clothes hanging someone
gambling and then goes right to kidnap
and murder arson drug dealing and
bribery law provisions and racketeering
convict to serve up to 20 years in
prison and in addition to fine up to
$25,000 that's like if you're going to
jail for 20 years
who gives a [ __ ] about the fine you know
hey man you're going to jail for 20
years also your OS 25 grand that man
I'll really talk about it I'm making a
[ __ ] den you're in jail
you're surrounded by [ __ ] cinder
blocks take all my money who gives a
[ __ ] what am I gonna do what we're gonna
do if I had the money buy a flat-screen
not loud
hey dude take all the money in my bank
account they seized his 1.5 million
dollars which by the way is hilarious
because he's old he had 1.5 million
dollars in his bank account like he's a
[ __ ] like he's an Asian that just
moved to Southern California that's like
well I don't you know I don't know what
to invest in yet but he that's so much
money to have in your bank account to
just have it rolling around in your Bank
of America [ __ ] savings account
although house-sit house hilarious is it
that a rapper a hardcore rapper even has
a bank account like that he's like yo
dawg hell yeah and then he has to go to
[ __ ] Bank of America or Wells Fargo
to make a deposit with his [ __ ]
Rainbow Brite hair but she's a cool
chick I think that uh so anyway he got
caught on racketeering like it's the
Prohibition era and he and he's going to
jail for sure because he broke his
probation he was like yeah don't say
gang fights and so he just don't say
gang fights in your song and so he was
like okay and then brought a gun and
there was a shooting and he was like I
just like how real how real do you have
to be you know how [ __ ] real do you
have to be and how much do you have to
be it that's what I want to know when
you're a [ __ ] rapper this guy had it
all he trolled his way to the top and
then was just too real so keep it real
my my thing is out there keep it real
but also don't keep it that real because
you keep if you keep it that real then
you're gonna go to jail for 25 to life
and then
um yeah man
dude it's call so crazy like this guy's
gonna get out of disc she's gonna get
out of jail in like 25 years or whatever
and and people are gonna be like
remember that [ __ ] person and people
are gonna be like no you know oh yeah he
she had [ __ ] blonde she had the disc
is gonna get [ __ ] in prison - wow it's
crazy that I start to feel bad for
people who are like that even because
he's like he's just a pro he's a product
of his environment you know what I mean
it's like you got to put a person like
that in jail otherwise we're just gonna
keep doing [ __ ] like that
I don't know anyway whatever it's a
[ __ ] sad story yeah she did it to
herself but it's still a sad story um
you know the whole thing is sad but
whatever let's not get it two down let's
like it two down in the [ __ ] podcast
cuz I'll tell you what I woke up early
for you babies I have a [ __ ] full day
couldn't do the [ __ ] yesterday because I
was busy doing the gameshow to tell the
truth just a [ __ ] because I Oh
needed a little bit of [ __ ]
did to it guess what did [ __ ] two
episodes so [ __ ] extra papers give
that up fresh off the jet to private how
long does this [ __ ] fresh off the
chit Sakura extra paper scooped that up
um so yeah so I did that so I and now I
have a full day today but I woke up
early for you baby so I woke up at
[ __ ] 8 o'clock and I'll tell you what
dude a lot of you guys wake up 82 Clark
you got those those those that early
commute and you're listening to me at 8
o'clock in the morning and you're also
listening to me at 5:30 when you're
driving back home before you have to be
with your family
and roll your eyes because your wife's
mad at you for something and I get it
dude I get it and I'm here for you
I'm listening me right now on your way
home from work
I am here for you I know you don't want
to go home and deal with all the
[ __ ] and then Noel said you love
your wife and I know you also love your
kids but I know you don't feel like
because you're tired and I know you love
your husband and you don't want to go
home or or you're either driving home
and and you got to go meet your husband
and your husband stays at home with the
kids or whatever it is or if you're
you're you're a stay-at-home mom because
I know in this cult we have a lot of
stay-at-home moms because that's my demo
45 year old women who have 12 year olds
that's my demo but um and I know and I
know it I know life is stressful but you
know we're here for you babies we are
[ __ ] here for you okay welcome
probably for you guys to do this could
have done it Wednesday didn't want to do
it Wednesday and also it's Thanksgiving
so I hope you [ __ ] have great plans
on Thanksgiving but whatever you know or
if you're alone that's sad and I'm not
gonna pretend like it's not get friends
yeah I got to go to San Francisco on
Saturday which I'm LA I'm happy about
let me tell you some about San Francisco
and people don't talk about this enough
the weather in San Francisco always
[ __ ] sucks donkey balls
no matter what it's
dude it's freezing no matter what August
you freezin
hey December you're freezin course Nach
also March
if reason spring but still freezing and
instead Francisco you like but wait why
is it freezing still because it's March
and like all right yeah but it's spring
sometimes it's a freezing ok cool April
still freezing and also May why is it
still freezing but San Francisco let me
check you right there in July
hey dead dead summer life reason because
of the wind yeah now what we need to do
in San Francisco is build a bunch of
[ __ ] I talk about a wall Trump wants
to build a wall in [ __ ] Mexico no
build that [ __ ] on the [ __ ] right at
the [ __ ] end of San Francisco so the
wind doesn't blow because that wind is
free I don't know what the [ __ ] up
with San Francisco but it's always
freezing I swear it could be hell on
earth the world could be exploding and
also it'd still be freezing and insane
San Francisco and you just be like glass
is still freezing maybe like I don't
know and they'll be like they're
dropping bombs and everything and
everything is on fire the lines are
still freezin you still be in a [ __ ]
you can still be in some ice cream in it
wouldn't be a mountain so I'm going to
San Francisco and then I'm going to
Boston I'm doing the wilt Wilbur theater
for shows sold out and then I'm doing
Medford which is not sold out yet in
Boston near Boston but anyway so I'm
going on the trip taking my [ __ ]
opener I'm taking Zak danke vo that's
the guy who laughs like that if you
don't know he is my [ __ ] tour guy and
I'm taking him and let me tell you
something about this [ __ ] first
of all let me tell you some of our
opener he always he's the kind of he's
the guy and I want to talk about this
cuz I don't understand people like this
all right especially we go to places for
one night the people who the first thing
he does what how do I bring this up the
people who go to the hotel room and on
pack do you know what I'm talking about
they don't just zip open their briefcase
zip open their suitcase and then put it
on that [ __ ] thing that all hotels
have just the suitcase thing like you
don't need that that's a waste of money
just put it on the floor but they have
that likeness to pretend like it's nice
and fancy but they'll even have it at
the Days Inn it's like a thing you open
up to put your [ __ ] suitcase on it's
like relax days in you're not fancy
because you have that [ __ ] fold-out
thing that you put your suitcase on what
the [ __ ] is that even called a suitcase
tan anyway whatever it doesn't matter
that thing right there yeah
suitcase tan I guess luggage rack that's
what it is don't have a luggage rack
days in hay days in get rid of your
[ __ ] luggage rack you know why cuz
you know what I mean I catch [ __ ]
polio in your rooms anyway you don't
need a luggage rack to spice things up I
still I still it still feels like when I
when I turn on the shower I'm getting
pelted with [ __ ] what is what are you
[ __ ] paintballs Hey Dude am I at a my
[ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] am i playing
paintball or am i turning on the shower
in a Days Inn you turn it on it's just
like Robert you know what [ __ ]
showers suck let me tell you this is the
worst cuz I stay in some nice places
because I'm not gonna I'm dude I'm not -
first of all I'm not I'm not sparing any
[ __ ] expense if I got a if I got to
be in these [ __ ] cities some of these
[ __ ] ass cities like Buffalo I'm
staying in the nicest which by the way
the nicest place in Buffalo sucks donkey
balls but if I got a stay these guys I'm
sparing no expense maybe I'm staying in
the nice places I'm sitting on nice
places where where you check in and they
just act so insecure just cuz they want
to help you uh hello I said Leah I'm
okay so uh hello mr. daya everything
just so you know there's a complimentary
breakfast
always with the complimentary breakfast
at 6:00 you know we start at 5:30 a.m.
and it's over at 6:15 a.m. so if you're
a goddamn Cowell you can come down and
you can eat if you're an owl if you can
come down and you can eat food because
the only people who are up from 5:30
a.m. to 6:15 a.m. are Alice so if you're
gonna howl if you can't move your neck
no I I don't know why it's Mark Wahlberg
[ __ ] Mark Wahlberg the only person in
a landmark Wahlberg that's who it that's
who wakes up for the complimentary
breakfast for an owl if you're a man or
if you're Mark Wahlberg you can wake up
and you can just hey what's going on
oh I get a [ __ ] a butcher howls in
here what the [ __ ] am i doing working
out just trying to be better gonna eat
my complimentary breakfast and then go
work out with some owls it's just
[ __ ] mark wahlberg and some owls at
the [ __ ] complimentary breakfast
dude go [ __ ] yourself man make the
complimentary breakfast 11:00 okay make
it at 11:00 and maybe that's me because
I'm [ __ ] sick or make it at least
make it go through 11:30 start it
whenever the [ __ ] you want but dude it's
always like it's always it always ends
above even if I have an early flight
that I say it always ends before my
flight then I have to leave I like I
gotta leave my flight ID when you leave
it when you leaving tomorrow 7:30 a.m.
whoo sorry the complimentary breakfast
ends at 5:15 a.m. but if you're an owl
if you're an owl or Mark Wahlberg feel
free to stop in and by the way just get
some oatmeal and raisins or some hot
coffee because that's all we have those
complimentary breakfast suck dick dude
[ __ ] your complimentary breakfast
that shit's free cuz it's leftover dude
[ __ ] your luggage rack and complimentary
breakfast you've got damn days in anyway
I go there and and so I go to these nice
places and let me tell you these [ __ ]
let me tell you what I'd rather have the
days in shower that feels like you're
getting hit by some [ __ ] paint guns
I'd rather have that then the shower
that they try to make nice that looks
like it would be in a [ __ ] futuristic
movie with jeremy renner that you'd walk
in with it by the way no door on a
shower go [ __ ] yourself
put a door
I don't care how fancy it is I don't
care how much we were supposed to feel
like jeremy renner walking into a movie
in the [ __ ] 2035 i don't care put a
door on it you know why ground gets wet
know why almost slip know why you almost
get a lawsuit that's the thing - I'm not
gonna be the guy who sues either that's
the worst part if I slip and cracked my
head
I'm not litigious am i litigious my
babies no I'm not litigious I was way
too old when I figure out what the word
litigious meant by the way but um yeah
dude I'm not suing so that's the thing
to have a door on your shower so the
water doesn't leak out and also but
these are the worst showers and that
besides the door here's the thing - if
you're gonna have a door on your I got
rules you [ __ ] if you're gonna
have no door on your shower you have a
[ __ ] shower head that's attached to
the wall not the ceiling okay
these [ __ ] shower heads that come out
from the ceiling or a bullish [ __ ]
they're disguised as the nice but they
are not nice and let me tell you why
dude cuz when you take a shower and guys
with long hair and chicks know you don't
always want to [ __ ] wash your hair ok
if you're bald doesn't matter if you got
short hair doesn't really matter but if
you got the ceiling [ __ ] thing and
it's shooting down on your head it's you
can't you can't get your [ __ ] it you
can't really position your head you can
see in the video podcast but you can't
really position your head to not get it
on your [ __ ] hat hair and and here's
the other thing to people like wear a
shower cap which I'm all for I [ __ ]
I'll wear a shower cap I don't give a
[ __ ] dude that's not just for ladies
I'll wear that [ __ ] but when you're
waking up early in the morning you're
not thinking where's my stuff
you're not thinking where's the shower
cap where's this where's that you just
get in the [ __ ] shower okay
so put your [ __ ] it's not nice I
don't care if it looks sleeker or
whatever put the shower head on the Sai
on the wall dude and if you've got no
door you better put it on the wall
because that [ __ ] top showerhead from
the ceiling constantly spills out into
the [ __ ] outside of the bathroom and
what were what you're trying to do is
you're trying to make us litigious
you're trying to make us litigious [ __ ]
why would you try to make us litigious
daisen hey no not the Days Inn there's
some [ __ ] like the [ __ ] Soho grand
would do it or the Mandarin Hotel in San
Francisco you did you trying to make us
a little teddy suit yo [ __ ] nice
hotels you trying to [ __ ] make us
dead you said I I mean I don't who the
[ __ ] would listen to this podcast is
what I want to know I talk but I swear I
talk about the hard-hitting issues this
is a real [ __ ] you can go out there you
can listen to your [ __ ] political
[ __ ] you can listen to what's going on
you can listen to the New York Times
podcasts you can listen to you know sam
harris and all the real [ __ ] or you can
come here and you can listen to the
hard-hitting [ __ ] that's really a
problem with the world and really what's
going on like top-loading you're Berber
and the [ __ ] ceiling showerheads and
putting them on the wall because I'm
just trying to [ __ ] fight
for a better society dude there's all
this extra [ __ ] that people are trying
to do that make the world makes the
world worse keep it real babies keep it
the way it was we figured out how to do
it we figured out how to do it
don't let art and fanciness [ __ ] up with
the way we do it because this is how
this is how we done went it's all of the
days and then you come in here and you
get autistic and [ __ ] it up that's what
happens you think I mean cool but you're
not being cool and then you step in fall
and you get [ __ ] up and then get
litigious that's not cool
Donnell Rawlings just texted me man
sorry to hear about 69 son I know how
close you were
there's a killer on stage Donnell
Rawlings let me do these ads here mmm
here we go my babies Robin Hood hmm
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
Kryptos all commission free Oh
Commission free what are we what are we
brokers other brokerages charge up to
ten dollars for every trade but Robin
Hood doesn't charge Commission fees
trade stocks and keep all of your
profits profits so trade stocks and keep
all of your profits easy to understand
charts and that's coming from me dummy
easy to understand charts and market
data place a tray a trade in just four
taps on your smartphone Robin Hood web
platform also lets you view stock
collections 100 most popular sectors
like entertainment and social media and
curated categories like female CEOs and
analyst ratings of buy hold cells for
every stock learn by doing this is one
of those things you just you go to and
you learn by doing it learn how to
invest as you build your portfolio it's
very cool
and his learning experience and also you
learn how to do it and then you're much
smarter and you can also make money this
way discover new stocks and track
favorite companies with personalized
news feed custom notifications for price
movements so you never missed the right
moment to invest just the way the app is
designed it's it's cool and you know you
feel cool doing it but Robin Hood is
giving listeners a free stock like Apple
Ford or sprint to help build your
portfolio so sign up at congrats dot
Robin Hood com that's Congrats dot Robin
Hood com me undies this is the year that
you can finally tackle your holiday
shopping early dude I never do this but
you can do this with me undies is a
great thing to do it with you can get
everything you need for you and your
loved ones at me undies me undies uses
the coveted micro modal fabric which is
three times softer than cotton if you
never felt this fabric what you should
doin get ready to experience pure bliss
in underwear form it's great
I wear them wearing them right now I got
on my ones with the two cans on them or
whatever the birds on them but you can
also get the the holiday Styles which
you know you can get the the Jack
O'Lantern one I have for Halloween and
the holiday plaid which is great for the
holiday you lands around in holiday and
doing it cool with your babies speaking
of prints this holiday season me undies
will be releasing a new print every
Tuesday that means you'll have no excuse
not to celebrate the holidays right down
to your very core so get that and then
give a gift on on the holidays great
offer for my listeners for me undies for
any first-time purchasers when you
purchase any me on these you get 15% off
and free shipping it's a no-brainer get
15% off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on to get your
15% off your first pair free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to my undies comm / Congrats that's
my undies comm / Congrats square cash
you already know the cash up is the
number one finance app on the App Store
what you might not know is that you can
also put cash
in your wallet with the cash car it's
the only debit card that offers instant
rewards and comes packed with premium
features not even a credit card can
offer like boosts save up to 10%
instantly at Whole Foods Wendy's or
Chipotle and more of your favorite spots
or even $1 off coffee every time you
swipe a cash card at coffee shops across
the country the cash card puts you in
control of your money with extra in-app
safety features that let you pause your
card with a touch unlike a credit card
there are no fees ever it's free and a
credit check isn't required to get one
download cash up now and get your cash
card for free and of course when you
download the cash app and enter the
referral code Congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 to the times up Legal Defense
Fund a true win-win visit the App Store
or Google Play market now that's quite
for like a real talk show host when I do
this isn't a talk show this is a [ __ ]
podcast man this is not a podcast this
is a cult you understand so yeah man
anyway I couldn't read the rest of
donnell rawlings texts on air because it
was ladled
and riddled with the n-word so anyway um
dude
so what else man I don't know if some of
these know I have write known at these
notes I got to be more specific
oh so yes or my opener packs unpacks in
a hotel that's weird man will get there
and he'll [ __ ] take his shirts and
his pants hang them up put them in the
drawer like war what are you a [ __ ]
lady what are you moving in for 19 hours
we're here for [ __ ] 19 hours it's you
know it's weird that he puts his day
outfit the outfit ready for the next day
he'll have laid it out on the [ __ ]
lounge chair yeah do it he really does
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] I walk in and I'm
like what'd he do
no what are you doing and he's like it's
never watch just what I do it's nice I
[ __ ] lay it out he's got like a
t-shirt by the way it's always some
sweat some swag that he got like a free
thing like a podcast shirt and it's like
come on bro
and and and just like shorts because
he's because I'm gonna work out so I got
a you know I got the [ __ ] shorts here
and then and then I always have like oh
by the way Zach my [ __ ] tour guy now
dude he [ __ ] has always um like in my
rider I'll have I always got that that's
what I got my rider when I get to the a
rider is what you have when ready for
you when you're there to do the show
always have salmon and some vegetables
Tabasco sauce club soda and it and a
toothbrush I like with toothpaste but
they always like that's not a lot I owe
a lot of people people will go crazy
with the writers like I'm sure Katt
Williams is like I need a [ __ ] sheep
there too you know strippers a sheep and
some [ __ ] peanut butter that you can
only get in like Wisconsin you know and
so so they always like you know pepper
it with other [ __ ] like to put like
pretzel bites or like other you know a
Clif Bar too and sometimes they'll just
have like starbursts which I never eat
that [ __ ] but Zach eats like a [ __ ]
dis garbage disposal and also it so
anyway so he has so eat so so I'll note
it I noticed too like whenever we get
early morning drives because sometimes
we don't fly after the show the next
night it's Chloe did you try to route it
so it's close so you just have like a
two-hour drive to another city and they
just perform in that city now so we got
a drive and you know I got you got the
driver and then there's two rows of
seats me and Michael sit and
my opener sitting one and then he'll sit
in the back and in [ __ ] it like 9:30
in the morning I'll just hit will just
be tired of [ __ ] because we stay up way
too late for no reason watching Forensic
Files and you just will just be a little
bit and we'll just here and I'll look
behind me and Zach's got the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that they left for me like skittles
and he's just like and I just like are
you [ __ ] opening candy by the way my
candy that they left for me in the green
room at 9:30 in the morning are you
opening gummy bears you [ __ ] trash
bag are you opening gummy bears at 9:30
like it's part of the [ __ ]
continental breakfast and then I'll just
be like and then I'll just be like well
whatever you're not gonna eat it and
I'll be like yeah but dude it's candy
and it's 9 ah gross he's got like a nice
tea we'll go to Starbucks and I'll get
an iced tea and [ __ ] egg bites and
eating the skittles that we got from the
night before dude like what is it it's
guy is always Halloween for this
[ __ ]
Kasich has saving candy like it's
November like well eight I ate the stuff
I liked on on October 31st and November
first but I'm saving it this guy
God what a big kid and he's also got the
highest ass in the biz dude his ass is
so high it's in his shoulders this high
wipes this our website he takes a [ __ ]
the video podcast you gotta check that
out this how my buddies act on Covell
wipes after he takes a [ __ ]
dude his ass is so high even the foot
even you know black guys have high asses
black guy looks at Destiny's like oh god
damn his ass is so on his asses his
shoulders so that's cool
hey man you [ __ ] not your shoulder
blades he's get the smallest [ __ ]
esophagus and what do you call it work
in small intestines it's all bunched up
in his [ __ ] throat the back of his
back the back of his backpack smells
like [ __ ] because he always farts on it
so dumb dude so dumb oh man he can get
and I can't believe anything else I
don't think I'm [ __ ] out he get
[ __ ] in the butt joke and also do
something at the same time but isn't
that really doesn't really work oh man
he's so funny
yeah I think he what's up with this
[ __ ] my buddies are talking about
Riya it's like a app these apps hmm I've
never been on a dating app but and I
don't I don't say that like I'm better
than that
I I don't I think it's cool I thought I
I don't you know I don't think it's bad
to be on a dating app get your [ __ ]
Shh get your [ __ ] get your bolts wet
however you can you know but yeah
everyone's talking about girls don't I
don't think girls really [ __ ] do the
dating app thing they did they play it
like it's a game you know my buddy was
saying he was on riot I'm stretching
being [ __ ] respectful his [ __ ] but uh
my buddy said he was on rye and he was
like he kept on encountering like
married chicks like that were like
happily in relationships they just
[ __ ] swipe left and right like
they're playing bejeweled they don't
give a [ __ ] it's not riah to them it's
it's [ __ ] snake remember that song
movie about a like a snake charmer um
it's a specific wait was I gonna say
though I was talking about Riya and then
damn it I had something to say is are we
doing this [ __ ] podcast and I can't
remember it goddamn it was gonna be
funny and I think or maybe not probably
not probably [ __ ] not I don't
remember
doesn't matter yeah so there there on
that I don't know whatever oh wait you
know what I want to talk about this is
amazing first of all I want to talk
about this [ __ ] thing that was
invented called jaws or sighs okay now
this guy is on Instagram I follow him
cause sway to funny but this guy's a
thing called jaws or sighs okay now this
guy it's it's called redefine your
jawline in only five minutes a day tone
your face and neck okay so it's called
jaws or sighs now this guy was in a
motorcycle accident which is no joke
he's got like half his ear missing but
he's a good-looking dude they put them
together battery you know and the gays
in [ __ ] shape for sure
i I but without even explaining it okay
I'm just gonna find the best here we go
here we go this is this is what this is
a good one this is what I'm gonna it so
you put it in your mouth and you chew it
but it's let me just try to have this
guy explain it to you guys yes adventure
of Jaws or sighs so I had the level one
the slimmer the toner you boil it one
time to fit to your front teeth okay so
now he's doing it he's chewing on the
jaws of Sighs and pointing to his jaw
like showing you where it works but it's
a game changer i batch roster size with
a 100% 60-day money-back guarantee if it
doesn't work for you simply cut in half
for a full refund
it's that easy with two thousand
combined reviews on jobs besides Dahmer
Amazon Prime you got nothing to lose
till next time finish for your face dude
the best is Ray says he is tagline is
fitness for your face and he which says
first fist for your face like say the
tea and fitness dude fits for your face
until next time fits for your face
speak speak right if you're gonna
workout you're gonna like say it right
it's for your jaw the everyone's gonna
think you're [ __ ] up it dude
Jazzercise comes you live from now
you're why with some facial Fitness
that's why I'm so drunk after a
motorcycle accident left me in a coma
for 13 days and I three straight for my
bike and I proudly kept it made right
and now I feel better making fun time to
fit to your front teeth you gotta see
this
I've been coming so hard [ __ ] a robot
they right here in the USA with four
levels of resistance whether you look at
the slim toe strength or bulk or simply
cut in half for a full refund
it's that simple by now jobs besides our
comrade was all prime till next time
finish with your face
Aloha duty flexes his jaw at the end
it's the best you got to go to Java size
on Instagram and what do you guys got to
get it and see if it works this is a
promo for it too
but dude I just like whatever you're
trying to slim tone bill bill bulk or
bill I don't know what the you know
who's trying to [ __ ] bulk their jaw
who's trying to [ __ ] oh Jesus Christ
this [ __ ] world dude props to the guy
for doing an American business and
[ __ ] keeping it you know real you
know legit I guess people swear by it
some people do but it's just so funny to
me you got to see it sir I'm realizing
now when I'm showing you guys this you
got to see it a remedy for the puffiness
that was under mention I'm model and so
I was looking through some of my photos
and saw that I had this puffiness I
workout and the java size is perfect for
me because it's a workout for your job
the music really able to do it when
you're on your way to the gym or leave
going to work when you're laying in bed
it's super convenient and it comes in
different levels that targets what
you're trying to do and helps to achieve
your goal for that perfect jawline so I
am definitely recommending John's size
for anybody who's having any issues or
trying to tighten or giving a puffiness
in the jawline chin area go and get you
one
she's cute
when she said it and made me want to buy
one um I gotta get well you know what I
gotta get one that's the thing I got to
get one and and do it on this podcast
and I'm gonna do that I mean dude
George's has finished for your face well
you're looking the same tone bill or
bulk or just waste of money just with a
new small that's right folks it's
finally here 33% smaller than the
current Chavez highs before resistance
levels where you look at a slim tone
strengthener bulb the Java size that
will work for you you boil it one time
if they're doing that point newest jaw
there you have it folks a hands for you
american-made work with a 60 day how
them sent money-back guarantee
I'm sure we have nothing to lose so by
now jobs besides Dahmer Amazon Prime
until next time for the street your face
Aloha I needs flexing his jaw and the
best is that the end he goes like this
why is it still going dude some Tigers
are he points it like if you're watching
the video the puck is BAE goes like this
finish that ball I'm over one time we
were faced and strengthened in waited
strengthen tone build or bulk in a
finisher for her face any was good
he's always like trying to find the best
way to point to his jaw to like a be
like when he does his golf okay man Wow
okay there's so there's the blue level
one slimming and strengthening pink
level to tighten
in strengthening purple level 3 toning
and strengthening green level for
bulking and strengthening so basically
all of these help you strengthen your
jaw but one of them only one of them
helps you slim it and only one helps you
tighten and only one helps you tone it
and only one helps you bulking bulk it
who was the Titan their jaw who goes
what's up hey how's it going oh no
you're very good
what's different about you think Djoser
size and no my jaws tardies [ __ ] I want
to get the while you don't want you know
let's get the two because I don't want
to be a [ __ ] let's get the tightening
and strengthening one we're getting that
Jazzercise how much is it there 33%
smaller now 30 bucks all right kind of
swing it yeah get me that one on the
Amazon or whatever tooth and I'm in
Aloha way and you think I'm not gonna
leave a [ __ ] review dude I'm gonna
leave a review okay so yeah I don't know
but so there was that that guy makes me
laugh dude he makes me laugh dude I sit
and I watch it for [ __ ]
I mean minutes laughing dude so there's
that and then there's this guy too
that this guy who I found
doing spoken word poetry and it is
here let me just say right off the bat I
am NOT a fan of [ __ ] really any
poetry you Robert Frost because here's
the thing are you in the year [ __ ]
you know 1612 or are you in [ __ ] now
then what are you talking about
the wind for what are you talking about
the [ __ ] wind for what are you
talking about the clouds for whoops yeah
this [ __ ] is I'm gonna find this [ __ ]
here because I don't play on my computer
fish for your face this [ __ ] was the
some [ __ ] I found that was sent to me
and it is a great know this guy you got
a tweet this out but this guy I've been
thinking about first of all it says we
are creativity spoken word by Kurt
Peloquin I don't know how I found this
it's got three hundred and thirty three
views but man that's how we do it
I'm not a fan of spoken word so I'm just
gonna say that but I'm gonna make I'm
gonna you know this guy I'm probably a
good guy and you know what dude anybody
out there doing their [ __ ]
congratulations that's good dude trying
to make a [ __ ] IIIi don't know what
this guy just listen to this
I've been thinking okay about creativity
okay as a two-way street up and down the
mountains of our life oh well just going
down for supplies before we embark
toward uncharted heights advance of gear
he's doing this he's walking down the
[ __ ] Street and he's doing like this
dense of gear and we [ __ ] we got
creativity I've been thinking of
creativity from [ __ ] Indiana Anna and
he's doing like that [ __ ] okay so here
he keep going he keeps walking the
cameras going with him in front of him
he did Britney Spears both you [ __ ]
straight-up did a Britney Spears much he
says and takes bottlenecks and to the
bottle breaks he's doing like that guess
if he's white or night why white or not
[Music]
we might meet our minds and we conquer
the side of the blank page an empty
stage strangers gaze and seize our days
you see I think it boils down quite
simply to the fact that we are
creativity
splitting cells naturally stretching
crying craving to see taste touch feel
and breathe believe in grieving and
still deceiving our own design Minds
like okay I'm not creative okay well
okay I don't dance and I definitely
can't see
out of the laughs not even in the shower
about after two or three happy hours
when your guard comes down and you feel
your power the power to play to make
your way from the bed to the moon but we
keep burying our dreams and tombs of
it's too soon they won't understand but
you start a crying better not stay and
what's the point anyway the point is any
way ah learn about what you love and
show us how it moves you how it shows
you the way because you decide if you'll
leave or stay and it begins and it ends
today it's a way the scale of give and
take will make no mistake there is no
given fate there is only live and make
make memories make thank you cards make
strawberry shortcakes make new friends
bad choices funny voices make love like
a [ __ ] rocket ship
oh he swore to keep every time to see
something you've never seen make someone
make up a [ __ ] Ciroc ok flowers big
room for more and more mistakes along
the two-way street of love and hey what
even is easier to see something you've
never seen makes bound smile make
yourself a bouquet of flowers big room
for more and more mistakes along the
two-way street of love and hate fear and
faith laughter friends bad choices funny
voices make love make a [ __ ] rocket
ship uh-huh what like time to see
something you've never mistake so long
the two-way street of love and hate fear
and faith laughter and waits from time
to time to take in the view
your life is not only the things that we
do life is me nice
it's you then walks away
you know what dude you know I was
laughing at this last night but I
thought but this [ __ ] would help some
people you know I mean it's it's
definitely pretentious but this guy is
probably a [ __ ] good guy and I Betty
Betty I bet he like is so nice but guys
like this I have you know what I bet
he's a [ __ ] this kind of guys again I
bet he would I gotta you know I can't I
don't know what to make of this guy I
want I want to I want to meet him though
I bet he's a [ __ ] nice guy
you gotta be a nut well let me tell you
something - if you're gonna be doing
this kind of [ __ ] you gotta be a nice
guy
make a [ __ ] rocket ship I don't
understand that part I'm a dumb [ __ ]
I'll tell you that see people like this
[ __ ] this guy writes comments the only
comment this was awesome may I posted on
my facebook page and do you have a
Facebook page why do people ask that
it's on the internet dude oh man I
really love that video you posted for
for all the world to see do you mind if
I share it it's what do you mean it's on
it's not somebody's [ __ ] address the
guy made it for that and the guy didn't
even respond he's too busy making a
rocket ship
when did they post this oh wow
it was [ __ ] over a year ago I like
just III go backtrack I mean the guy's
being pretentious but I like this guy I
bet he'll make and the way the [ __ ]
it does so many hand movements it's like
he's in Minority Report like he's
checking the [ __ ] future make a
[ __ ] rocket ship man baby was the
music that was going on during it but I
felt like I almost cried he would [ __ ]
your girl for sure is if you look at him
he looks like the guy looks like he
would be an extra in swingers that movie
in 1988 make a [ __ ] rocket ship so
anyway
get now I'm sweating my balls off that's
what happened man oh wait I got the
[ __ ] quiet fan I forgot we're almost
done anyway you got Twitter questions
coming up I was thinking about did you
guys ever watch The Golden Girls that
show that somebody gave me a shirt that
had the Golden Girls on it a fan gave it
to me and that show I used to watch I
was talking about my grandparents the
other day with my family and I was
thinking about how the difference
between them and all that and I have one
grandmother left are the other ones
passed away and I really liked all my
grandparents and I was thinking about
how my grandma Dottie felt more like a
mom to me not not more like I'm on them
than my mom my mom felt like my mom but
felt more motherly to me and my grandma
Carmela is Italian I felt more like a
friend you know my grandma Dottie is
still alive
ermand I still love my grandma Carmela
died years ago from cancer from cancer
because everybody gets cancer and then
we got to figure out how to cure cancer
because everyone dies of cancer so
that's [ __ ] a big problem but she was
felt more like my friend cuz we used to
have like sleepovers I mean my brother
used to go over there and we would watch
hunter and the Golden Girls and I
[ __ ] loved it I loved the Golden
Girls dude and my grandma would always
be like come on time to watch the Golden
Girls and we'd all like I mean I was
like [ __ ] seven and my brother was
like four I would go and watch the
Golden Girls with my grandma and I loved
it dude I loved it because my grandma I
don't know why I loved it I thought it
was funny
but how weird is that that a
seven-year-old loved the Golden Girls
you know I just jump in a bed and I
remember that [ __ ] blanket to that
she had it was the the flimsiest blanket
it wouldn't keep you warm at all but I
would go in there and it would be my
brother in her and we would just be and
we would just fall asleep we watched
hunter and the glue watch Golden Girls
and then Hunter came on and they would
always fall asleep
the end of Hunter and we loved it dude
and my grandma had a swordfish hanging
in her basement and I was scared the
[ __ ] outta me I would never go in her
basement cause it was a goddamn
swordfish in there but it was so fun to
do that and now when the I had a fan
give me the Golden Girls shirt I made me
think of my grandma and I was like oh
that's so [ __ ] sweet that you know
the fan didn't even know that but but I
now I think of my grandma when I see
this shirt and I loved my grandma but I
don't remember much of things I never
really remember [ __ ] I have a really bad
memory and I remember that like I don't
remember like one time when my grandma
was dying
she was staying at my parents house and
I went up to her room and I was like I
know she's gonna die soon I should sit
and talk with her and like learn about
her and all that stuff and I said I
talked with her for like over an hour
maybe two hours about how her life was
and how she met grandpa and how she you
know different parts of her life and I
was like I got to remember all this
stuff and I don't I don't remember I
have a bad memory but I remember I did
that I remember I oh I connected with
her so that's kind of important and that
was really sweet
but I do remember the [ __ ] and watching
her watching the Golden Girls with her
and I do remember watching I do remember
that [ __ ] blanket man I liked that
blanket and I liked the Golden Girls and
I loved being at her house for some I
don't know I don't know it's weird what
you like is a [ __ ] kid what you
remember I wonder if I brother liked it
too I should ask him we're gonna make a
[ __ ] rocket ship is what I'm trying
to say but yeah I don't know once I was
at my grandma's house and for some
reason we thought it was a good idea to
take mud and throw it at the house next
door I don't know why we were little
kids I didn't even think about how it
might be bad and that people came out
from next door and they [ __ ] when you
yelled at us they were like you gonna go
to jail we're gonna call the cops on you
and then I ran inside crying and I was
like they're gonna call the cops
and my family was there and they thought
it was so funny they were like they're
not gonna call it con I could get a rat
can we get arrested
like an actor get [ __ ] arrested for
throwing mud at a house you're [ __ ] 9
ha ha ha
man we let over they've [ __ ] laughed
at me dude Wow [ __ ] it's crazy remember
that [ __ ] seems like another lifetime
you ever think about your guys you're a
kid when you're a kid you don't even
[ __ ] think about like how I mean so
long ago another lifetime man I kind of
watch hunter again is what I got to do I
gotta watch the Golden Girls again all
right we got to wrap this up I got to do
this phone call but you guys remember
phase 4 your face and so download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google or Google Play market and two
rewards code Congrats get five dollars
give five dollars - times up the store
is back get the new wouldn't make a
[ __ ] dent shirt so people know that
your [ __ ] bank account is dent 'less
and it's continuously being restocked
Plus Black Friday deals my babies you
guys are the best
and we'll get that log cabin soon but
subscribe to the YouTube channel follow
the leader'
new dates for 2019 on on sale we got the
The Wiltern in Los Angeles this weekend
and San Francisco and Boston coming up
Boston coming up in Fresno and what else
Bakersfield Austin and San Antonio
Austin and San Antonio st. Louis Phoenix
so go get those tickets now they'll sell
out subscribe rate and review the show
it really helps and all that videos go
up the next day always download my app
to see it first to see it first you can
download my app
yeah that's it remember dude no the
[ __ ] rocket ship huh
[Music]